So I've made a small change to my app.
And I'm just changing the location
that we're actually looking at.
And I've set it to be the latitude and
longitude of the street right outside
the studio where I'm filming this.
So I called panorama.setPosition on
this, and I do everything else the same.
And I'll show you what
the app looks like.
Here you can see the area outside
the studio, and I'm on Latham Street.
And you can see Latham Street
in the street view itself.
And if I go to other places,
we can see Showers Drive and
the other part of Showers Drive.
And as a result you can see all
the street names being updated.
Here we can see Showers Drive
again from this angle.
So street names are on.
And you may want to turn this off.
The default value is
that it would be on.
Now let's take a look at what
it takes to turn it off.
Now, if you remember, it was just
panorama.setStreetNamesEnabled and
we'd pass at a boolean.
I want to turn if off, so
I'm going to set false.
So now I'm going to rerun
the application and
we'll see what it looks like.
And here's the same application running
now with the street names turned off.
And you see I can just
see the view outside.
The street names have
not been overlayed.
The default behavior was for
street names to be there, but
I've overwritten that, and in some
cases it might make for a better app.
It's really up to you and
what the needs of your app are.
Play with the others, the user
navigation and the zoom gesture, for
yourself and
see if you can get some nice effects.